the EU produces more than 79 billion
tonnes of packaging waste every year and
that amount just keeps growing
less than half of it is recycled or
turned into compost sorting centers like
this one in Brussels are already in high
demand just completely employee per year
officially the Universiade
Sonora diferencia no per been a colored
a photocopy ranked a met on a
disposition EU Mercato quali caper Lauro
so no scar tea cake Winnie Tolliver un
valor economic oh the European
Parliament has set a new target 70
percent of all waste should be recycled
by 2030 compared with just 44 percent
today
one-third of municipal waste goes to
landfills though for some Member States
it's more here in Greece three-quarters
of everything thrown away ends up in a
dump like this one step in a cocoon
commodious Allah a fortune tripod poon
it was - the party hoary poof pollutes
with your face body so they could never
fight en ese the Laveen of the action
applause and a for oh you know meta
Fuhrman that's cocaine economy al
cometary them in LEC a peach festival
developing a social process misty
kurama's yeah after safari
conspiracy opposite gimmick Torah and
abbiamo fair a llama is Trina captive
Adobe amo
sure Kerry did our mnemonic Westie pay
easy areolas are all infrastructure EKG
say you know petrol altro and karamurat
acidic logic Adama Prevost by 2030 EU
lawmakers hope to rely on landfills for
only 5% of all waste
88 million tons of food are wasted in
the EU each year mostly by households
some of them have already changed their
ways this Spanish family living in
Brussels is new to composting and
doesn't shy away from leftovers
[Music]
president Akina Alimentarius accessible
around camp
- are you Cho Seon - t-midi Shamu
ambiental a messianic un tema su chale
EDT kosanovich Oh [ __ ] amo piu permitir
que su mag Randy quantitated chibita
melatonin la ceiba venomous para cada
semana Boniface report says nothing
edible or reusable should be thrown away
that's the only way Europe can reach its
goal of slashing food waste by half by
2030
[Music]